the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
might as well get started so this is all
carrying on the conversation that we had
last time we talked about you know is it
the case that you know country countries
have for possibly for very long term
historical reason some countries might
have very different kinds of
institutions from others in particular
well some might be much worse than
others in at least in as using the
standard measures and then what do you
do about it and sort of the first
reaction is sometimes well tough right
you know if the story is that you had to
have some some lucky break 400 years ago
to get get the institution's right then
it's it's not entirely clear that
there's much you can do about it that's
sort of the pessimistic view now there's
the people so this is this is before the
people who really worried about these
issues there's an interesting debate
going on where there are really the it's
really between these four four people
listed or five people listed above are
on the two sides of the debate one side
of it is a Stanford professor called
Paul Romer who ghouls has come up with
this idea of charter cities like charter
schools so he wants if you like to
import institutions so his basic idea is
the US has good institutions so a US
firm or a US NGO would start you know if
South Sudan wants to have a city then
they should just can hire a US firm to
set up the city for them have the same
guarantees that the US has so it will be
a part of the part of the US
institutional frame that's a
so it's not clear exactly how that works
because for example suppose you set up a
quote in that country and it is under
you as the US laws but the judge in the
court decides not to implement those
laws does the u.s. invade who's making a
commitment so this is a set of real
issues about you know how you get that
to lease the waiver or your tongue
lovely they basically give it up as soon
as citizen kind of successful I mean
have at least a copy there
circumstances under which wildly visit
Bridget originally the colonizing the
hopes of happiness own commercial and
equally importantly they handed it over
to under circumstances when they really
didn't have any choice oh yeah so being
Britain is certainly no position to
let's say disagree with China on about a
city that's next to us to China so there
was no there was there's no leverage
their whatever so yeah so the several
issues there you just brought up one
which is how do I make the kind of D if
you like the to use your word the
sponsoring country give up the city then
there's the opposite problem how do I
make sure the city actually runs and
who's guaranteeing it will you know is
it the case that suppose the suppose the
judge in who is supposed to enforce in
the US laws in I know benin is doesn't
do it who's going to be the who's who's
liable to make it happen yeah
right so
the same way I'd like colonies
for years
right so so so you're right i mean
there's a question of the demand side
for it maybe no there is no country that
wants it but let's say that there is I
think Paul's presumption is that there
are countries that would like to have
better institutions they cannot
domestically manufacture it but if some
if they just somehow important
institutions and there was a guarantee
are behind it then it would work so
you're you're pointing to a completely I
mean what you're saying is completely
right there needs to be a demand for it
if the country doesn't want it there's
never going to happen but let's say the
country even wants these institutions
anyway even were even in that case there
are several problems one is how do you
actually run a charter City I mean who
you see who's in charge and is it the
case that suppose a you know is the u.s.
prepared to back up its whatever its
commitment to the church charter City if
it says the US laws does that mean the
u.s. is going to send in an army
whenever the laws are violated this
like exactly so what did commitment
absolutely so all forms of commitment
are an issue obviously you know it is
not enough to say that we have us-style
loss in fact if you look at across the
world lost don't vary a lot what very
easy a legal system is very limited
relatively little what varies is the
enforcement of the law so you have to
make who's watching that the laws are
getting enforced yeah
part of that because they have like
economic
so as it's on like a much smaller scale
it's about that's the only thing those
instances are generally speaking the
cruise line owns all the land is private
property they kind of stuff in town
so it's like a hotel but a large hotel
like in a song about how have the
internal currency it was once entrapped
into this completely horrible hotel we
had this internal currency with high
inflation as I could tell because
wherever I wanted to buy something so
basically you go into the hotel it's
like a resort and you can spend there
that they give you a certain amount of
currency and you can spend it anywhere
you want in the resort but it turns out
that the prices are extraordinarily high
so so there was there was so that's sort
of the same idea
so why is it different from a hotel
where you resort where you can go from
like one shop to another and their shops
are competing why is it different
because it is like one thing that's
different is there is like like a major
industry there that creates demand
whereas if you said some city up
africa like where there's not already in
that
right so so part part of it is that
there is an economic engine that's
that's already there and that so you're
saying then this is chicken and egg
problem which is that the city would
only generate value if it is it comes
with an economic model and the economic
model isn't there already if you just
get into the institution's how good does
it as a guarantee need to be before the
economic engine arrives that's sort of a
challenge that you might imagine that
the problem might be that if I tell you
that you know I mean cote d'ivoire in
the middle of the civil war but we have
this Enclave that's protected you really
need very good assurances of protection
before some industry is going to be
willing to move move to this Enclave in
Cote d'Ivoire in the middle of the civil
war so you are always this question of
who guarantees but also I think there is
the question a third question which is
what's to stop the country from
withdrawing its concession so this is
the country gave you some land you build
a lot of buildings you got a few
factories running there what's to stop a
country with bad institutions was coming
back the next year and say well now that
we have all these factories I want them
and who's going to stop that with the
u.s. sending an army to stop that they
seem like there are myriad issues of
implementation which seemed makes this
rather wacky scheme yeah
you're going to build the longest city
of graduates all that and all the
existing
yeah not to just you know what what is
the you know how do you did with the
inequality and all that within the
country yeah sounds like she proposed
happen he mentioned the timeline for
these cities because although you might
have the framework for good institutions
man of Law's respected and that's
somewhat the cultural issue that if you
grew up in a corrupt society you have
any kind of graining you how to go about
change so it will take at least one
generation or several generations to get
people to change your ways and actually
follow the law and help make it these
institutions work for example kind of
Russia transiting from the communist
society to democracy they have all
applause
on institutions but people still have
this whole mindset that's not working so
that I think that's that that goes back
to the first point we were saying which
is that the evidence on institutions is
says that if you got the right accident
which major institutions the right ones
you know 200 or 400 years ago then that
persists that doesn't say anything about
transplanting institutions but I think
romo is posing exactly he's asking the
right question which is imagine that the
US has good institutions can a US
company set up a take advantage of the
fact that is a US company and us as good
institutions to set up a kind of a
chartered city in kill Cote d'Ivoire
which will have good institutions so
he's kind of exactly he's thought about
this issue he thinks that well the way
you do it is you import institutions
that's that's the idea and so in some
sense you're totally right that you know
it's not you is not enough to just write
down the rules of the institutions and
that's completely right but these knees
not saying that he's saying that plus
implementation will come from us company
the question is whether US company can
implement anything like that yeah
we will be serious
but to some degree it is closest thing
to what room are suggesting or kind of
scene and after I mean Afghan army in
iraq we need a lovable midwest monetary
involvement military expenses and
they're trying to create a new
institution so doctor because the
example case in the future one kind of
changed institutions on white scales and
they obviously believe this is a site
but it's worth reading the book is
called imperial life in the Emerald City
or something it's wonderful book it's
about is the Washington Post bureau
chief in Iraq after cover a year and a
half their wrote this book about the
implementation of us institutions in era
and what was wonderful about the story
in that book was and this is relevant
for very good what we're going to talk
about it a bit so it's not entirely an
aside so the book is wonderful in
describing exactly how the u.s. went
about institution in implementing good
institutions in Iraq so basically the
rule one was that the people who got
hired to do that we're either staffers
of prominent republican congressmen or
senators or prominent contributors to
the Republican cause those are the only
people who were selected second most of
the staffers who were given
responsibility for for example designing
the stock market laws where 23 year olds
who had a background who had an
undergraduate degree in accounting was
sent to set up these laws as a result
and there was usually one person who had
you know for her you you know somebody a
23 year old with a under
degree was assigned to be in charge of
setting up the stock market or in
figuring out how to you know reform the
legal system so these were people with
strong background in being Republican
operatives and no background in actually
running any institution so this is the
book is wonderful in that it sort of
goes through how how the whole process
was so doomed from the start because the
institutions people who were said to do
these institutions had no competence
whatsoever in doing the job because they
were all political appointees and it's
quite actually the book is actually
worth reading and it sort of calls back
to a point i'll come back to later which
is that you know imagine you wanted to
make institutions better you still need
competence and it's not just a matter of
of having you know some playbook from
the US it's a matter of actually having
the competence to turn that playbook
into reality and i think that that's
that was part of the very major problem
in iraq in fact that's not let's go back
to the
so then there is Paul Collier who will
who has a different view who says and in
some ways I think this view I find less
unrealistic maybe less defensible but
less unrealistic which is you know if
the country has really horrible
institutions just invade this is sort of
the this is at least internally coherent
much more I think internally corner than
the roamer suggestion which I do not see
how it would be implemented but this was
you can imagine at least the policy
prescriptions simple invade and then
just set up colonial rule for a while
this has been tried it's been
implemented in the past we know how kind
of how it is to be done so there is no
implementation problem you might have
various objections to it I think but in
many ways this is this is a more
difficult one to challenge on on purely
a prior I grounds I mean one of the one
of the sad fact is that we know very
little about the effect of colonial rule
from history that is to say if you look
at places that didn't get colonized so
few of them didn't get colonized in the
so unique like China is one country that
didn't get colonized it's but if you
basically most poor countries most
countries outside Europe and the North
America were colonized and as a result
is just very little and when you compare
the ones that got colorized with the
ones that didn't the ones that didn't
get colonized we're like Japan and China
and those are not random draws from any
population so you you is very hard to
hard to see what the effect of being
colonized is the one exception to that
that I know which is not quite perfect
but it does a little bit of that is a
an MIT PhD student some years ago
lakshmi iyer did this paper well what
she did is she looked at in India there
was a what is called the doctrine of
laps the docking Oh laughs was a
beautiful idea so the way India was
colorized with bit by bit and then the
bits that were get God some [ __ ] was
left out at any any point they will
fight a battle take over some land and
then some would be left out and then
they'll have a treaty with the local
potentate at that time for to set up you
know to have a kind of a dependent ruler
so there was a so basically India in a
basically this process of colonizing
India ends in 1857 with a with about
two-thirds of India and a direct British
rule and one-third of india under rules
rule of a whole bunch of rulers 500-odd
rulers who were each had a little small
territory and was the king of that
territory and had a treaty with the
British the British basically were kind
of overseeing this person so that's how
the caller I didn't happen now one of
the ways in which the British would take
over one of these little kingdoms was
under what was called the doctrine of
laps the doctor own labs was a you know
one might say cynical idea but it was a
it was the idea that if the King didn't
have a natural air then the kingdom will
lapse to British rule so you basically
what this paper does is she it is
compares places which do so this
doctrine of laughs basically enforced
very heavily for eight years from 1848
to 1856 during this period about 20 20
places had the
had the sort of the King King King died
and i guess some of those places had a
male natural heir natural air means a
son basically and the other places
didn't so what she does is she compares
the places which had a natural air with
the places we didn't have a natural air
so if you look at these places if you
think that the birth of a male child is
kind of a random accident then you might
say that these are comparable and on
most things they do look comparable if
you look at these places 150 years later
the places that were under British rule
do works in almost every attribute that
can be measured they'll you know less
good infrastructure less good education
less good other things so that's the
only piece of evidence I've seen that
has some some bearing on this question
it's still a very special set of you
know still 20 places so I would say we
don't we know very little about the even
the economic effects of colonialism and
then there are the all the political
effects which are that you know color
colonists are often you know they create
hierarchies and those hierarchy is
create all kinds of resentment and a
whole bunch of stuff other stuff that
potentially can go wrong and I but I
don't think there is a great natural
experiment that tells you what would
have happened had you know had whatever
LGD had not been colonized everything
anybody knows here yeah
Colin matter so much on the major why do
we why we want to make a general
statement oh I guess the question is
whether or not you want to interact race
with with with colony you get much worse
outcome you almost surely do the
question is whether that's interpretable
or not well if I said that take take
colonies which are non-white colonies
they do a lot worse than white colonies
now what that means i don't know but
that's that's what I I I do think that
if you you could make a firm hypothesis
which which I don't think is testable
given the data that if you were
non-white and you are colonized by white
people you ended up badly it could make
the hypothesis it wouldn't be rejected
yeah exactly so I i did i'm not saying
that you could resolve this question I'm
saying you but the hypothesis would not
be prima facie rejected by the data but
my point is only the only that we don't
know I wasn't saying more than that I
would just say that it's not an
implausible hypothesis but one that I
think I I don't think we know enough to
answer call us question I actually don't
think that this is a realistic idea
because I don't think anybody is
prepared to do actually I think if you
look at the u.s. the real problem with
getting the u.s. to be a colonist is
that the u.s. actually loves the idea
maybe of you know being influential in
the world but it doesn't actually like
the idea of having young US soldiers
fighting to protect some foreign land
from its own internal conflicts that
just doesn't is not a politically
popular idea so I don't actually think
any countries volunteer to volunteering
to be a columnist and that might be a
good thing but it is certainly true that
I think after the Vietnam War the US has
had enough of I thing long term
colonialism I think that's a that's a I
think that's the given so I don't think
there is any country that's volunteering
so again I don't think Collier solution
whether it's right or wrong I'm inclined
to believe it won't work even if you
tried but that's a stat apart I don't
think there is any evidence that anybody
is willing to do it so it may be moot
and then there is a bill easterly who's
been very critical of bought Roemer and
and Collier and his position is very i
would say internally consistent his view
is that you really don't there's nothing
you can do to help countries countries
have to help themselves there is no no
sense in which it is really any outside
wisdom that's useful with an important
caveat i will come back to minute but
there for you know Oh lonerism won't
help because it's not countries help
themselves the Seltzer serve their own
problems you can't really help any any
country he's not in
Ali doesn't quite stop there which would
be really internally consistent whether
right or wrong is a different question
he says except you should have pre-trade
democracy and capitalism those are the
three things that he's in favor of and
then he's not really in favor of
anything else so he does believe that
those three things can come be the the
country does not have should not have
choice on those dimensions but once you
have implemented those you can let them
leave them alone so he's now again the
problem is that there is not much
evidence I mean certainly some countries
have figured it out there is no way it's
not clear that that's there's any
evidence that the process of figuring
out is a particularly efficient process
that we've talked a lot to this semester
about policies that were you know tried
and didn't work and they didn't work for
very good reasons this is so in other
words there is a lot of knowledge out
there that useful for countries who
countries to use so it's not clear that
you want to take the position that
countries need to make every mistake and
figure it out so that there is a and
it's not even clear what a country means
when is it is it really the case that if
I think of Tunisia under ben ali there
was a while you know a collective
experiment in dictatorship it doesn't
seem like that's the right right
description that you know so a country
is just a set of people but it's not
clear that there is any organizing body
which is implementing a national
experiment I mean maybe some countries
are but most countries seem to be just
you know when they fail they seem to be
not doing anything particularly
interesting some guys stealing a lot of
money and the rest of the rest of the
people are suffering that doesn't seem
like necessarily a recipe for you know
it's not clear that's a symptom of the
process of figuring out
you going rather than just a symptom of
failure and then I think the most
internally consistent are definitely our
colleagues Acemoglu and Robinson whose
view is very much that there's nothing
you can do to help help but also then
mostly nothing good will happen so the
their view is I think most solidly I
think internally consistent you know
basically countries are probably screwed
if there and yeah
yeah but I I know Jim very well I know
him very well I think you would say he's
a pessimist he might be trying to do
something but i think is well i actually
think i would say that he that's the
most internally consistent of all these
positions that you see is is the one of
saying that look you know if I really
believe that institutional changes are
very difficult and they only happened
because of you know major historical
events then is internally consistent to
be pessimistic because you know you why
would we have much hope and I think they
are they the example they give off
basically of changes are the French
Revolution and the Glorious Revolution
there's two examples that they mostly
spend a lot of time talking about the
fraud so these are two examples of I
think major shifts in you know so their
view is that it's change is possible but
you change happens when internal forces
within a country just happen to be
aligned in the perfect way the and they
give these two examples of the glorious
revolution in Britain in 1688 and the
French Revolution 1789 as the two
examples of where you know you just have
the right alignment of forces and then
the internal compulsions of the country
just drove the country towards good
outcomes that in each case these were
just moments of liberation and they gel
did wonderful things for the country
there are many many other such
revolutions and they've been less
successful you know the Russian
Revolution the Mexican Revolution the
Chinese Revolution may their many others
you could go through and they've been
less successful clearly so their view is
that is not enough to have revolutions
you need to change society's massively
you need to have revolutions but
revolutions are not easy mostly they go
wrong
it's only when you have the lucky
matching of different forces that you
get the right outcome and therefore
mostly there's not much you can do you
can get lucky if you get lucky things
will work if did not there's not much
you can do about it and that's very
consistent with the view that they have
from there I think must go there
evidence that you know all we really
know is that if country has got it
router dry right several hundred years
ago then that seems to persist so when
good things happen good things build on
each other but it doesn't then we have
no recipe for creating good things so
that's a very very think pessimistic but
very very intended but I think in some
ways admirably I think internally
consistent point of view
JJ
treaties even on insect I table
so in your assessment or in jail
so I'm going to actually argue that lots
of institutional changes are possible
that I just they are possible we added
at a different level from the ones that
we are talking about and so I guess I
would agree that many things change
within countries indeed I would say that
if you look at you know status of women
I mean the stunning fact over the world
is how much has changed over the last
150 years not that there's not a lot of
change and i think it's the change has
happened in China as much as it's
happened in in in the US and in China
was an extraordinarily i would say
anti-woman country and you see massive
changes going on so I I'm going to argue
mostly that there is actually lots and
lots of possibilities for changing
institutions just that you don't this is
this is asking a different question so I
guess what we want to argue in the we
argue in the book is most more mostly
lots of things change they don't
necessarily change wholesale and you
don't necessarily get you know better
institutions in in any sort of macro
sense but that doesn't mean that things
are not changing all the time even
within political systems which are bad
so it isn't the case that you think of
you know for example very countries
which have had very large improvements
in education and health indonesia and
the Suharto which was extraordinarily
corrupt was often rated the most corrupt
country in the world and was under a dig
an extraordinarily repressive dictator
who at some point is claimed killed a
million people by labeling them
is in the mid-60s nevertheless if you
look at what was happening in Asia
Indonesia between the period of 19 over
72 and 1990 he is one of the world's
biggest most successful sort of
investors in human capital in the world
you see big changes in education levels
you change see big changes in health
suharto was very very concerned about
the Indonesian health nutrition and he
created whole campaign a nationwide
campaign of young people going back to
villages and you know bringing message
of better nutrition and its claim to
have improved nutrition massively in
Indonesia so this this is I think so in
other words I I think that that's not to
say that Indonesia became a better
country immediately or that there was no
corruption went away I mean as in fact
corruption or during the same period
that education is improving in Indonesia
corruptions also going up you soo hot is
becoming more and more corrupt as his
children get older they're becoming more
and more richer richer and buying up
larger and larger share of the country
so there was not that there was a
one-way movement in institutions and
indeed that's my point that this is this
is not this is this isn't there is no
sense in which there's one institution
in place and one set of institutions in
place there are many many things going
on in any country and many of those are
getting better others are getting worse
you I think we're always looking for
leverage points where you what are the
best places to who best places to make
make a you know a small push and see
where we can make a change so once we
start thinking about institutions within
capital letters in small letters other
institutions in
capital letters so like not capitalism
but how a specific market is run we do
see lots of changes and that's the level
at which you should think of of
institutional change yeah like the
chances that they'll actually work just
because there's so far beyond what we
can observe tests and sort of day-to-day
things like that that you would always
want to take the path like that the
doing graduate reform would be like the
passive path of lesser resistance all
but then i guess like like you know
germander omaha this
the type of about this thing called the
seesaw like will you make one dimension
of institutions better than other gets
worse to compensate or Jeff Sachs would
say that like we need to change
everything I was on and I mean do we
actually have I mean I guess that Jim
Powell have a little bit about that's in
their paper but do we really have much
as in the way
so I know I don't I so it could be that
you know you that they're there right
that there is some inevitable that you
can never improve anything without
making anything something else was I
find that implausible let's say but I'll
leave that as a as a main point I'm
trying to make here is a simpler one
which is that there is no grand theorem
which says that every everything that
you can change is determined by some
overarching institutional frame that
even within bad institutions there's
lots of things that do change some for
the better some for the worse and that
that there is enough slack within the
system that you can often change things
even when things look pretty dire so
here's an example Chinese in Chinese
Democracy this is not well known because
you know China is not supposed to be a
democracy whenever China introduced
village elections quite early and if the
elections were phased in so you could
you could compare places which had
elections with places which had a
centrally appointed village head so this
was just a comparison of what happens to
a place when it becomes elected so you
basically seemed to see that you see a
quack when when these institutional
changes happen in a place like China
which is after all not a democracy huge
control of the Communist Party certainly
whenever there is any real attempt to
change institutions at the high level is
been stamped out with a great deal of
clarity listen we never been any sort of
debate on you know how did you know that
didn't challenges to the power of the
party have not been entertained on the
other hand so you might imagine that
when China introduces village elections
these would do nothing because you know
power has not shifted every this the
same people have power turns out that
when you introduce the elections you get
very large changes and this is not now
this is this started I think in the 80s
so when you start introducing elections
you get very large changes basically two
things happened one is the central
policies that are unpopular unless
enforced so villages the one-child
policy which is the policy of not
allowing people to have more than one
child is relaxed much faster in places
which have elections that's so somehow
despite the fact that the central
government is all-powerful when the
villages has an election it does enforce
different things second one other very
important part of Chinese policies
relocation of farmland basically what
they were doing was you know they would
for example take farmland from farmers
and build like cities or roads or
industrial estates or special economic
zones and things like that and basically
when the village had elected government
that stopped or went down a lot so you
couldn't take land away from the farmers
that easily and this is with the
all-powerful state which was which is
supposed to have impunity it was still
true that they could make many changes
within that system and it's so striking
how much there seems to be even in a
system like China how much
responsiveness there is two local local
demands once you start democracy so you
might have thought that well you know
the big institution is there is no
democracy in China
let's the China is classified as a non
democratic state yet at some level China
is actually quite democratic at the
local level and that sort of a way to
understand also why China has sort of
managed its conflicts relatively
effectively is because there is actually
pressure valves at the local level which
allow it to let off pressure so there is
there's a sense in which this is not I
think this is an example of why we
shouldn't sort of look at on you know
institutions from a thousand miles up
but we should look at how the function
on the ground a little bit and I think
equally importantly so we I just talked
about why bad institutions in capitals
like lack of democracy doesn't really
necessarily always mean there is no
democracy on the ground the opposite is
also true that you could have good
institutions meaning good electoral laws
fair you know nominally fair elections
but those elections may actually not be
at all fair and here's a nice example in
Brazil there was a complicated paper
ballot system so you Brazil has for the
last many years has had free and fair
elections since about the mid 80s and
yet in the electro Brazilian electoral
system for a long time people just
didn't think about it so you would have
to write in the name of the person who
you were elected or the number either
name or number you have to say mr. seven
or something and since most of the many
people are not very literate when they
write the names of somebody it is
illegible so as a result eleven percent
of the names were rejected at any in any
election that's a lot like eleven
percent of the votes were rejected
some huge amount so they basically this
was taking too much effort counting what
was too too complicated so they
basically replaced it with electronic
voting you had to press a button so
basically that meant that the invalid
votes went away and as a result the
fraction of of the elected
representatives who were who were
uneducated or poor a less educated
report was went up the poor were voting
for people like themselves as a result
health expenditures went up and a sort
of a a bunch of pro-poor policies were
implemented so this is an example of
where Brazil was had goodest
institutions in capitals to start with
but somehow those institutions weren't
doing what they're supposed to do so if
you looked at from a thousand feet up
you will see good institutions but that
doesn't mean that the institutions were
actually doing what what they were
supposed to be doing and so about ten
percent of the population of a huge
proportion of the poor were
disenfranchised you know eleven percent
of the votes were eliminated that means
that you know if you take the poor
probably thirty forty percent of poor
were disenfranchised they didn't they
couldn't work that changed the nature of
voting and change the nature of outcomes
so it's sort of it's a beautiful example
of how you know something kind of nobody
thought about this it's not that anybody
had this as a conspiracy this was not
somebody's plan it just was something
that was just there people thought paper
ballots a fine nobody had thought about
it once you once you change the rule
then you must change the rules not to
fix it but to just make it easier to
count votes it turned out that that had
massive consequences
this is the picture I'll just skip the
species so here's a another couple of
nice experiments so another sense in
another sort of one argument that like
Paul Collier makes a lot of is he says
you know the reason why you have to
invade this country's that these
countries are always they have too much
internal conflict that they can't govern
each other themselves because they are
fighting each other all the time he's
actually Paul is very sympathetic to
these people you have to understand he
is a very very soft-hearted colonists
color imperialist he has he you know I
I've known him for many many years and
he's certainly not someone who's cynical
about this this he certainly does really
believe that these people are just they
are in court in this eternal fight
against each other they hate each
other's guts and so therefore they can
never govern whenever you know one group
takes over it starts beating up on the
others and that's why you always have a
cyst permanent state of civil war and
conflict see they're just not capable of
governing each other because there is so
much fundamental hatred of each other so
to look at this a layered one check on
who's a was a political scientist from
Benin did the following Leonard was in
the student movement in Benin in the
several late 70s early 80s and that's
one Benin was a I think many had a
dictatorship and so he went to jail with
all the other people who were run you
know leading the student movement and
says go very good friends with all the
leading politicians in Benin now so when
it is now a democracy and I think
and in the democracy he is good friends
with all the all the leaders so he
basically talked them into doing
something quite remarkable his idea was
let's hit every leader he basically cut
the following deal he said let's go to
the area where you are really dominant
go to the area where you really powerful
okay so you're never going to lose that
area you're always going to win that
area so it doesn't really matter if you
get a little less boards so let's do an
experiment where you send different
messages in different colored in
different areas okay so you you're going
to win within that area so let's say
this you know there's this region like
that where this is where you're totally
dominant you always go to win so now
let's chop this up into little pieces
and randomly choose some of them and in
some of this is all within the area
where you sure to win we do we're going
to randomize the message you send so
there are two messages they were sending
so this is the this is the message that
sort of is very kind of primes people on
on their narrow tribal interest if you
like this is says that the berry ba
people will get jobs okay we are i am
the representative of barber eve of evil
this is what Paul Collier is
particularly concerned with so this is
the the same guy going to different
villages and giving different messages
the villages are two randomly chosen so
you can compare what happens and they
were willing to do it because they were
sure of winning so they didn't have to
worry about winning their the question
was how much water how many votes do
they get this was the message the client
illest message the message that will
I'll serve you guys my people that's
what people are worried about here's the
public policy message same person
different village goes and delivers this
message I'm going to we will fight
corruption and promote peace among all
ethnic groups in all regions of penny
this was completely rigged he was given
they were given these messages they were
they agree to deliver it because they
were friends friends of his so this was
the this is what makes Paul Collier
worried so this was the first experiment
that Leonard did so if you look at what
happens to what shares if you go to the
villages where there is you did the
public policy message you got only
fifty-nine percent of the vote when you
did a client list message because
seventy-nine percent of the vort so that
was the so this is what gets Paul
Collier worried he says people is not
possible to have democracy in this
places because people are so narrow
minded now what happened let me just go
back is
okay see where they go
ok
I let me mention one more one more and
i'll come back to tej now actually so
let me show you one other experiment
before I come to this this is what we
interesting to show you one more so
here's an experiment that we did in
India where which is the kind of the
opposite of this one chicken experiment
so it has the opposite result and I'll
try and kind of interpret why so this is
so in this is the play this is probably
the most corrupt place in India and
about you know forty percent of the of
the people who are elected from there
have criminal charges against it against
them okay in this area we did an
experiment where we randomly chose
villages and in some of the villages we
basically showed up with a team of with
a puppet show basically we showed up
with a puppet show the puppet show was
to the point of the puppet show was to
say you know you should not vote based
on your cast which is the equivalent of
ethnicity in India you should vote based
on who's who's going to do more
development for you so that was the
message it was a completely neutral
message and the complete and the and the
neutral message is is you know was
delivered by an NGO people people you
look at what happened the people who
voted based on their for their ethnic
party went down by a quarter if we just
went and told people don't do it they
don't do it
so this is sort of the opposite story
which is you know in Benin the
experiment was that you went and told
people please vote for me or the best of
ethnicity then they seem to water
ethnicity if you tell people do not what
her necessary do they do the opposite
now is Benny indifferent I will come
back to that later but what this made us
think about was maybe the reason why you
observe this kind of ethnic ethnic
city-based voting is not because people
are passionate about the ethnic ethnic
roots sometimes they are but maybe a lot
of people are not but because they have
no other information maybe they do not
know anything about the candidates and
therefore you know if I have to have no
idea who to vote for there are three
people running i just bought for the one
who is the same name as me why because i
have no idea who they are I've never met
them have no idea what they believe in I
don't trust them to have told me the
truth in any case so do you actually get
the the
do you get the right outcome so so maybe
maybe the reason why people vote based
on ethnicity whereas we think that this
is somehow a kind of people just have
some you know some biological or
sociological hatred of those other
people and they can't resist voting in
fact maybe the reason why they vote for
their own ethnicity is only because they
have no better choices they don't know
anything about any of the candidates so
they might as well vote for their own
ethnicity so this is what we were
investigating I'll keep going yeah well
it seemed like it was like a way to
target things like I'm this ethnicity
and I'm going to get things for
neighbors i'm going to do good things
for you know everybody and i immediately
that would be so different than if
somebody was running for like you know
Senate in the u.s. I was like I'm going
to do good things for people of
Massachusetts versus i'm going to do
good things for everyone in the US like
I mean that's that so you may well be
right so that's another point but me
I'll come back to the bending in a
minute is the bending is I just want to
show this experiment and i'll come back
to the been in one in a minute so so
based on this idea that maybe voters
don't know who who who they're voting
for and therefore they just bought at
random and maybe they just vote for the
guy who has the right name or something
we did another experiment where we gave
information about the candidates to the
voters we told them look you know the
this candidate is I know more is more
works harder than that candidate we
showed newspaper printed people's
performance and you and when you do that
you see that people do do change the
voting patterns suggesting that people
don't really know a lot about the
candidates if you give them information
they react which suggests that
information is valuable to them they
don't really know what's going on ok let
me a now go back to Benin and i'll come
back to this so here's what happened in
many one second did a second experiment
second experiment was instead of people
just saying I'm going to do good for
everybody he actually had them run a
conference whether in the conference
they discussed real policies okay so
they had a long discussion of real
substantive policies experts were
invited and some policies and and so
parties took up the policies that were
came out of that conference and put it
on a platform these were well worked out
policies not claims about I will do good
for everybody
okay so that the only difference they
win any deuce the same experiment as
before in a different direction later
election it is the same experiment which
is telling some people you know here's
here's a you know either send an ethnic
message or an on ethnic message okay and
now when you go and tell i'm going to do
good for everybody that actually goes
the other way so when you say i'm going
to do good for everybody but it's backed
with a real policy proposal you get much
more positive results so it looks like
the voters were actually rightly cynical
about these politicians they were
claiming they're going to do stuff for
you know everybody but nobody believed
them because they had not put any
content into it when you actually put
content into what you are claiming what
does react very differently they feel
like you know there's some something
that's going on that may be worth
supporting so you see instead of this
you know strong reaction for the ethnic
point of view now you get the opposite
which is a strong reaction for the
non-ethnic point of view
okay let me talk so another example I
mean so the point I'm trying to make
here is that it's easy to that in some
sense what looks like sort of structural
resistance to any change says you know
countries are just hopeless they have
such ethnic conflict that they can't do
anything about it that might be true
under some situations but I mean for
example if you if you take country if
you want to name countries which have
had some of the most I think most
serious ethnic violence in the last 20
years yeah they include many countries
which are actually very economically
successful countries I mean so it's not
clear that that's something that's
actually that that strongly is that the
effects are that strong but even if you
believe it it's not clear whether ethnic
conflicts are a result of other failures
or a core the cause so in other words is
it the case that people are basically
cynical about the political system and
therefore they vote for a you know just
about the person whose name is the same
as this or are they is it really the
case that they are they vote for people
people who have the same name as theirs
and therefore the political system fails
we that that's sort of the challenge in
figuring out and at least there seems to
be some data which suggests that I mean
this this evidence that I've been
talking about suggests that it may well
be that to a certain extent if people
are cynical about the political system
makes them then vote more unreliably and
if you could actually get the political
system to be more effective then people
would actually be less inclined to vote
on s on the ethnic basis so in other
words I'm trying to make the case that
what looks like
if you if you like in Colliers view the
fundamental problem is ethnic hatred
whereas if it may well be that the
fundamental problem is just economic
failure and I think hatred is or ethnic
conflicts are just a result of that it
is not clear which way that goes and in
particular it could be very innocent
people just are completely it's not that
they hate anybody they just think okay
well you know if I don't have any
information I'm going to vote for the
guy who has the same name as me that
might be a significant part of what is
called ethnic botti his another instance
is interesting so going down the same
part of making the point that that you
you it is possible to that it is
possible so in other words so far what
we've been through I made two points one
is that having good institutions is no
guarantee that you get good outcomes and
the good institutions that we you know
at the thousand feet level is not a
guarantee that you're good good outcomes
on the ground level and conversely
having what bad outcomes if you look at
4,000 feet what looks like bad outcomes
may not be necessarily some things that
you should just take as well it's not
possible to do anything in this country
there may be lots of slack in the
country because for example even ethnic
preferences which is sort of seen as a
fundamental constraint may not be that
much of a constraint they may just be an
outcome rather than a constraint to
pursue that point that you know you even
that it's often possible to have
substantial changes even when the
economic incentives have not been
changed very much so you know the the
structures of power have not
change the institutions are the same
here's an example this is not so much
saying whether institutions are good or
bad to start with but to say that you
know UK is possible to change
institutions at the margin a little and
get big FX so here's an example Brazil
Brazil has this I am Brazil disinterest
in the political system Brazil is among
the most interesting in the world one
thing they do is every month 60mins
abilities are chosen at random and their
accounts are audited so you are audit
audit the accounts and then the audits
are basically these are there's a
lottery literally that's on TV the doing
a lottery is not not to declare the
winner of the of the lottery doesn't get
a lot of money the winner of the lottery
gets audited so you don't want to be the
winner okay so it's on TV so it's very
very transparent everybody can see that
it is really a lottery that's a big
advantage of lottery the audit results
are given to the government and
disclosed to the media so there is a
nice paper studying the effect of these
audits and basically what they do is
they compare places that were audited
just before the election and places are
audited just after the elections so like
elections and
in particular and it turns out that so
if you look at the average effect of
being audited before after elections is
not a big difference why isn't there a
big difference well turns out most
people don't find out the results but if
you look at the places which have a
radio which you have a radio station and
compare the places the effect of being
audited on places which have a radio
station with affected not being audited
on places which ever radio station you
see a massive effect people who are if
you are corrupt and you where you were
male from an place that had a radio
station and you are audited before the
election you are twenty five percentage
points less likely to less likely to get
elected then if you were from from a
place where you were you were a non
corrupt mayor from a place which has a
radio station and which was audited
before the election so if the difference
in election probability if you so what
we're doing here we're comparing places
that re-elected where the we are
comparing places that were audited
before the election and after the
election and we are comparing good
mayor's with bad mass so good mares are
much more likely to get elected in
places where the audit was before the
elections then whereas this little
difference between good mayors and bad
mares when if the audit was to happen
after the election so just this act of
just publishing the audit seems to have
substantially change the incentive for
corruption in Brazil so this is
something that this is not a this is an
example of something where the system
has not changed the whole system is the
still the same Brazilian democracy has
not changed a lot but just the fact that
the Institute in these audits means
you know being corrupt is much more
costly here's a this is the picture
which makes that point if you look at
the blue is those who got elected the
audit was after the election and being
corrupt has no effect on your reelection
rate whereas if he had zero if you had
zero code of violations and you were you
were you had a pre-election audit you
were 35 percentage minus twenty-five
thirty five percentage points less
likely to be elected then you if you had
three or more so if there was a
pre-election audit you post-election
audit it doesn't matter because you know
the election is done so getting
information is huge effects here when
these effects or magnitude which are
like it this isn't I mean clearly you
know you go from having a you know a
fifty percent chance of being elected to
being a twenty percent chance of being
elected just when you publish the
results so again making the point that
small changes in the institutional frame
the little institutions changing them a
little might actually give you big
effects
finally let me talk about up this
doesn't mean so I wanted so so far what
I've been trying to say is is a bit that
even within bad institutional frames or
without changing the institutional
framework generally you can make good
things happen that doesn't mean that
good things are guaranteed to happen
whenever you try things good things
happen that's not at all what I'm saying
so I'm saying that what what's true
about the economy at the thousand feet
level is entirely sort of one thing and
then there is possibly what what's
relevant at the 10 feet level and those
things are only weakly correlated so
it's not so in other words things fail
at the ground level whether or not you
have good institutional structures so
let me give you the example an example
of where the the institutional
structures were all kind of good Andy
and the system completely failed so we
did an experiment where there was a
district administration in India work
with an NGO to set up a monitoring
system to make sure that nurses come to
work nurses often don't come to work you
saw that I think at the beginning of a
semester with Esther and this is a big
concern for the health system because
you know you show up nobody's there
that's not so good so the way it was
implemented was that there was a date
and time stamp given to every nurse this
was just on mondays when she was
required to be in the center she was
required to stamp her presence on
something they were stuck to the wall so
she will stamp it there so that you know
people go she would have people could
check whether she was there or not so
she had to stamp it on the wall so she
had to be there basically and this NGO
was in charge of Colette
ting the stamps and making color and
counting their mobile giving into
government the government was announced
on a kind of uh so the district
administration was very taking this very
seriously they announced that anybody
who doesn't come to work more you know
at least fifty percent of the time will
get fired so there was a quite major
top-down attempt to reform so this was
kind of the you know the institutional
frame was doing everything it needs to
do so when this was announced
immediately you just compare the dashed
lines to the dashed lines I didn't tell
you the story of the solid line so just
as compared the dashed line to the
dashed line you see there is a very
major effect at the beginning the the
presence of the nurse goes from fifteen
percent fifteen percent come I mean they
don't show up at all to about fifty five
percent goes up massively when you
announce this program it goes up
massively they start to come to work and
that's not surprising you told them you
know and then what happens you see those
curves they were getting closer and
closer and they finally cross so I after
a while it turns out that if you tell in
the places where the nurses were
threatened with losing their jobs they
come into work less than where they were
not threatened so what happened why did
you get reversed
so what happened was very interesting so
two things happen the nurse has an
immediate boss whose job is to decide
whether the nurse needs to come to work
or not why because the nurses have
things like training so some days they
are not required to come to work those
are called exempt days and then this is
the date and time stamp had to work in
order to monitor the nurses so if the
stamp Braden step timestamp got broken
you couldn't monitor them now there was
a rule which said that you know if it is
broken they would have to bring it into
the center and get it replaced but still
you know once it gets broken it's less
easy to monitor them so what happened
was very simple absence did not go up
it's not that the absence went up the
exemptions went up meaning their
immediate boss basically declared fine
you don't have to come to work now on
you are not absent you're exempt so
meaning the boss said basically I don't
care if you don't come to work so i'll
give you an official excuse to not come
to work that was part of what happened
part of what happened was they started
breaking the machines machines started
breaking in increasing frequency and the
bosses who should have complained about
that didn't complain so it was the
machines kept broken breaking and nobody
was objecting so things were basically
the whole program collapsed now why did
this happen
is
so clearly this was a result of the fact
that the nurse and her immediate boss
were colluding that's not surprising but
the reason why it actually happened was
not because the institutional frame was
bad in some sense there is democracy
there is a there was a supervisor who
wanted it to happen there was an NGO
that was implementing it the reason why
it didn't work was mostly because there
was no there was no demand for it to
work that it wasn't it wasn't so much
the institutional frame wasn't there it
was just that the basically people
figured out that if it didn't work
nobody would complain and why would
nobody complained well you saw this
before nobody ever showed up in this
health centers in any case so there was
no one to complain so there's no
political compulsion to fail to fix it
and that meant that at some level there
was no no pressure to make it work this
is what we sometimes we call so we call
triple I or that the whole system the in
other words the reason why this
intervention didn't work is not because
the institutional frame was not working
but because there was no one on the
ground who actually wanted it had any
stake in making it work the the people
who were where nobody went to the health
center so nobody complained nobody the
the system was designed with the idea
that these nurses have some internal
desire to serve the people so this solar
system has no effective culture of
making sure that the nurses want to come
to work it's sort of men they never
invested in it and finally the there
wasn't no one had thought about the fact
that no one had thought about the
that then you know that the day there
was this exempt days and that these exam
days were not regulated so there was it
was mostly just the fact that you know
when this intervention was introduced
nobody had actually put enough thought
into into what what the nurses how the
system would react and so it was it was
not so much that the institutional frame
was particularly bad here in other
interventions do work it just that this
was a system where there was no no one
who actually had thought about how to
design an intervention to that that
would work and therefore it didn't work
indeed we when we went back we figured
out why you get this crossing why do you
think we get this crossing why didn't
you think the nurses came less where
they were incentivized to come
Oh in the situation where they were
these ones that you can
launcher it was only clear education at
it's one thing to have a composite
theory existing tries to enforce it but
if they don't and they try to enforce
this new policy and very quickly no or
student
enforcement that's a neat stronger
message right so they realize that the
bosses are very willing to collude with
them to not let them work this is a and
because they were very willing to do
that so because they had had a policy
which required their bosses to enforce
the firm now they could learn that the
bosses has no interest in enforce it
before this they didn't know that so in
the control villages they don't yet know
that the bosses don't care in the
treatment will exist they really learnt
that the bosses don't give a damn
whether they come to work or not so they
stopped coming to work so all of this is
not so making the point that is not that
we that there is the fact that the
institution's sort of whether the
institution's work the be students at
the thousand feet level work or don't
work I mean there is democracy here if
every lots of people what there is
political competition all of those
things that are supposed to make these
things work are all present the reason
why it doesn't work as is simply at the
micro level the incentive to make it
work is in there because you know people
don't go to the health center so nobody
actually demands that they have centers
work yeah
no the basically people have checked out
of the system so more people use the
health center but only by accident when
its open so the probability per day more
people are not present this is open more
often but it doesn't have any effect on
who gets treated ya / kappa / d yeah
Alyssa absolutely but you cannot fix
with this attempt to fix it was came
from a bureaucratic impulse which said
that you know how health center will
make it work and they just did not think
about what what require was required to
make it work which is to get a demand
for it otherwise it's never going to
work the political system only provides
incentives for things people want if
people don't one day the political
system does not provide incentives so it
got it was a classic example of a off of
trying to fix institutions without
really having understood how the
institutions work so I'll continue with
this next time